i promise you that christians love jesus
just as much as you love muhammad but if
i caricature or insult jesus i don't get
death threats as a result
all right
both statements both refutations i hope
you're ready because make sure you hold
on to your chair because you might fly
off they called the play insulting to
christians the message went on because
of you we will exterminate every member
of the theater and burn the place to
ground
ah i'm sure christian
the christians won't do that were they
why is this time so sensitive in it in
the comments mate let's let's let's go
straight to you yeah are you not the
same person who emailed muhammad jab to
take the video down of your debate was
support if i'm not mistaken why are you
so damn sensitive
yes that's correct not only does it
encourage you to read it tells you how
many verses you've read how many pages
you read how long you've been on it and
best of all the hasanah counter download
the qurani app now and have a ramadan
with allah's book like you've never had
before assalamu alaikum
brothers and sisters and dear friends
hope you guys are welcome now the
question you guys are going to be asking
is brother ali what are you dressed up
for is that a marriage is there a party
a halal one of course
well i've got something better guys it's
better than a party and better than a
marriage because we know when we go to
these parties or marriages you know
someone's getting married free food and
handling you're having fun it's going to
be greater than that it's going to taste
better than that brothers and sisters
inshallah whatever you get served in
your marriage events anyways guys so
this is going to be a reply to cosmic
skeptics
uh video titled why is islam so
sensitive what we're going to do
brothers and sisters as you guys know a
dehumidifier dehumidifies the humidity
in the air i'm going to be dehumidifying
the intellectual dishonesty and
corruption
in the air yes which is cosmic skeptics
video and we're going to go for this one
by one step at a time nice and slowly
and we're going to see
that how his double standards and his
hypocrisy yeah not just him many people
like him but before i start the video i
just want to make something and i want
to raise awareness to it
if you guys remember cosmic skeptic
after his debate with muhammad hijab you
know he's kind of went a bit downhill
you know intellectually we know what
that debate was and how it went
and he turned to doing videos about
veganism and he can do whatever he likes
on his channel you know he turned to
veganism and talking about this and that
etc and i think he's even a vegan
himself now today i was watching a video
on veganism i just wanted to know what
impact it has on the body when you stop
eating meat
because i had to
make a correlation between his pathetic
video and i had to make some kind of
excuses for him what caused him to make
such a pathetic ridiculous
video i mean actual academic dishonesty
well i found out something and this is a
statement it's a fact this video is
about being sensitive so if vegans are
watching this especially you know
because we're skeptic please don't be
offended yeah don't be so sensitive
sensitive yeah so what i saw was that in
a few the first couple of weeks yeah
first couple of weeks there alone not
eating for eight months or one year yeah
which cosmic skeptic hasn't i'm assuming
it says that vitamin b12 an iron which
helps make red blood cells and transport
oxygen through the body is affected
because vitamin b12 and iron helps
oxygen to go throughout the body because
it makes up the blood cells so the only
excuse i could come to is that not only
was there deficiency of b12 vitamin b12
and iron in his video it was also
deficient in his body because a lack of
oxygen being sent to the brain may have
caused him to do this video this is the
only excuse i could have come with
because i couldn't understand the fathom
how he could dare
there you i mean how silly can you be to
make such a bold statement and both
statements that come with bold
refutations like this video why is islam
seemingly more than any other religion
at least at the moment
so sensitive to criticism and mockery
that's a bold statement that's a very
big bold statement need to bring
evidence to that that islam is the only
religion or only way of life that is so
sensitive after all if i made a video
asking why jews react so violently and
intensely to criticism
you'd probably ask what am i talking
about and demand some examples
it's telling then that i don't need to
give you any examples of islamic
overreaction
because you've already thought of some
so here's this premise the premise is
the following guys yeah he's mentioned
if you mention the jews or argument's
sake another group of people or religion
whatever background whatever it may be
that he would have to find uh um
examples to give you to make sense but
when is islam we all know the moment he
mentioned that we all had 100 things
coming into our mind
okay so let me get this right guys and
tell me if i'm right or wrong and i
believe this is absolute fallacious
reasoning yeah if i target arguments say
chinese people systematically and
continuously i target them over and over
and over again
and i uh provoke them
i desecrate their scripture i mock their
religion or whatever it may be right
okay and as an atheist that they're
atheists as well imagine uh you know
you're called chinese how strict they
are yeah when it comes to free speech
um they didn't even at one point they
they had they banned winnie the pooh poo
winnie the pooh yeah because it was
mocking the president or something like
that yeah anyways
so imagine i systematically attack and
when they are provoked and some of them
that let's say there's a group of them
that choose to ignore majority of them
some of them insult back and some of
them get violent and try to kill me yeah
and then i go see guys look how
sensitive the chinese are
now how is that fair when you're
systematically only attacking the
chinese have you experimented with a
japanese have you experimented with
americans have you experimented with the
people in the united kingdom have you
experimented with the moroccans have you
expect experience i mean experimented
done a case study with all these groups
to come to the conclusion that we've
done the same thing to everybody all of
them in the past century and only the
chinese were acting like this no you
haven't so how are you using a case
study when you systematically not just
you
the western world systematically attack
the prophet muhammad peace be upon him
and the contradictory says which i'm
going to come to systematic over and
over again and that's the only case
study that you're using and you're
making it seem as muslims are the only
sensitive one not only that you make the
little group who act in violence as if
it's the majority
that's pathetic 1988 salman rushdie an
established and well-respected author
published a novel in the uk called the
satanic verses which parodied islamic
themes the following year the ayatollah
khomeini supreme leader of a foreign
country iran issued a fatwa ordering
muslims worldwide to seek out and kill
mr rushdie because the novel was deemed
to be so offensive to islam this is why
the question is such an often repeated
one why is it that islam is just so
violently resistant to any form of
mockery or criticism there you go guys
so once again as you can see he's got uh
khomeini from iran majority sunnis i
don't know i don't think they even
recognize his islamic state yeah
argument's sake let's suppose we do yeah
he
gave a fatwa which he gave one year
later by the way which could be for
political reasons we know people do all
kinds of stuff politic politics yeah
they even attack their own cells we know
false flag attacks that governments take
action um take on their own selves to um
to let it be a ripple effect towards a
war
governments do all kinds of stuff let
alone romania coming and trying to you
know oh look i'm i'm here to defend them
please yeah we don't buy and you're
getting that as some kind of case and he
gave six million to someone to kill him
and that's your only case study that
you're using now
let's carry on because it's gonna get a
little bit interesting
because let's see is there only muslims
that are sensitive or is cosmic himself
a bit sensitive as well or other people
as well let's get straight into it this
might get really real exciting guys
i promise you that christians love jesus
just as much as you love muhammad but if
i caricature or insult jesus i don't get
death threats as a result
all right both statements both
refutations i hope you're ready cosmic
make sure you hold on to your chair
because you might fly off there yeah
here we go guys yeah
intel intellectually you're going to get
dehumidified literally serrano's
photograph of a crucified jesus figure
submerged in the artist
in the artist urine urine has become an
icon in itself his christ was removed
from the wall kicked and hammered after
the local after the local catholic
archbishop failed to obtain a court
order to stop the peace from being
exhibited
exhibited in 2011 when the french
collection lambert in avignon showed the
work employees were greeted with
death threats
and the work again and the work
again was hammered most recently in
corsica protesters stormed the museum
where the piece was exhibited i'm sorry
guys i i feel so excited to do this
video that i even forgot to mic myself
up i had to stop the video and mic
myself up let's carry on in sean there's
nothing stopping us today inshallah
death fret by the christians those who
love jesus yes
truly who love jesus not the i would say
the majority of the western world who
are atheists now they don't really care
they do not care but for those who care
along the bible belt in america and in
different parts of europe they would
surely be knocking your teeth out there
was actually a video i came across where
a few teens atheists were mocking the
bible and a group of christian
youngsters came and knocked the thief
literally knocked them out there was
even a girl there anyways let's move on
inshallah the plastic religion
compromising 33 sculptures that
reimagined barbie and kendos as
religious figurines the ken version of
jesus on the cross in particular didn't
go down too well
the page the work the work the work
slated to go on display at proper
gallery in buenos aires in october but
the artists were threatened by
argentinian catholic groups and the
gallery director marcelo bosco decided
to cancel the show for security reasons
why are they so sensitive cosmic i don't
know last supper with a christ in a
woman's dress and high heels and
cross-dressing apostles with bdsm
costumes for an exhibition entitled echo
homo its first appearance in eastern
europe sparked a particular uproar
religious activists took on the streets
to protest against the display of the
exhibit in belgrade
serbia and around 2000 policemen had to
be called in to avoid violence breaking
out i can give many examples and i'm
going to put link to these you can go
read it yourself the statue of jesus
wearing mickey mouse ears entitled poon
was particularly controversial a
filipino television program deemed the
show offensive and public outreach
including threats to the artists ensued
the ccp ended up shutting the show down
why so sensitive in it why is islam so
sensitive terror ghanaian performed a
public russian square consisting of
hacking a series of mass-produced
orthodox icons with an axe in a
surprising turn of events te organia was
stopped while performing and punched
by fellow artists who saw his work as
offensive he subsequently emigrated from
russia
run for your life made russia under the
threat of criminal case for igniting
religious hatred again if this happened
in russia the orthodox exhibition was
vandalized by orthodox radicals and the
state sided with them the state sided
with them even charging summer
sommeredov with igniting religious
enmity and causing him to lose his job
at the museum why is islam so sensitive
made for more than 200 pounds of milk
chocolate and standing six feet tall but
after a group of catholics called the
work a sickening display and the artist
received death threats
and roger smith hotel which houses the
gallery shut down the show causing matt
selmla the gallery's creative director
just submitted his resignation the
catholic league also said the work was
one of the worst assaults on christian
sensibilities ever
why is islam so sensitive so the way you
make out and i've got more lists i'm
going to carry on guys we're going to
carry on here you make it seem islam for
the past century has been systematically
muslims have been massacred on in the
millions in the millions and we know
what's going on in afghanistan yeah
dehumanized to a level you make it seem
like we're just like i'm not open to
criticism we do dawah we are open to
criticism all day every day insult is
different to criticism know the
difference yeah so let's go to the
danish um papers charlie hebdo tiny
charlie hebdo and this is where it gets
so interesting my gosh my gosh it's rich
coming from you talking about freedom of
speech isn't it cosmic danish people
rejects jesus cartoons jalindus boston
the danish newspaper that first
published the cartoons of the prophet
muhammad that have caused the storm of
protest throughout the islamic world
refused to run drawings lampooning jesus
christ it has emerged today the danish
daily turned down the cartoons of the
christ three years ago on the grounds
that they could be offensive to readers
and were funny and we're not funny
my gosh you can't make this crap off can
you my gosh you cannot make this up
guess what they say next
this is what they said one of the the
ones i think they drew yeah
in the muhammad drawings case we asked
the illustrators to do it
i did not ask for those i did not ask
for these cartoons that's the difference
well it is damn different one of them
you're provoking doing it on purpose and
the other
you're not that's our point here sean
king's calls to remove white jesus
statue leading to ridiculous outrage
threats
why is muslims why is islam so sensitive
terence mcnally's corpus christ under
attack in indiana not just indiana new
york texas and greece they got bomb
threats they got bonfires check this out
guys the play featured a jesus-like
figure who has sex with apostles this
instigated white protest from the
christian right community notably the
catholic league for religious and civil
rights they called the play insulting to
christians oh christians they never get
oh come on
yeah they called the plate insulting the
christians and vowed to listen carefully
let me get ready for that one second
you guys ready so yeah here we go
i'm sorry i'm sorry i'm overwhelmed
this is what they said they called the
plate and saw the christian and vowed to
wage a war that no one will forget
against its production president william
sent letter to numerous public officials
demanding an immediate halt on public
monies public monies that support the
manhattan theatre club a group called
itself the national security movement of
america made telephone fest against the
jew guilty homosexual terence mcnally
the message went on because of you we
will exterminate every member of the
theater and burn the place to ground ah
i'm sure christian
the christians want to do that were they
why islam so sensitive in it cosmetics
yeah anyway as a result of these threats
and demands
uh transatlantic
transworld airlines and of the corporate
sponsors of the mtc withdrawals
financial support on may 21st the
manhattan theater club announced that it
was cancelling its production of the
play due to their concerns for security
after anonymous threats of violence to
the theater and itself
christians will never do that will they
nah
anyways the baby offers second apology
after recent homophobic comments why are
the lgbt so sensitive in it
um emmanuel macron my gosh you can't
make this stuff up at all imagine macro
takes legal action over hitler poster
comparison he was drawn as a hitler and
he's taken and this bloody
double standard hypocrite scum my gosh
the prophet muhammed's cartoons is fine
him as a hitler don't you dare don't you
dare sue you you dare to go and insult
the british flag yeah you're going to
prison mate yeah brittany patel crisis
uh criticizes racist cartoons showing
her as a fat cow in the guardian
why is he so sensitive for his only
islamic sensitive yeah not only that
mate let's let's let's go straight to
you yeah are you not the same person who
emailed muhammad jab to take the video
down of your debate was support if i'm
not mistaken why are you so damn
sensitive why did you email when he has
every right to put that up and he was
like no you don't have a right put that
down why because you got humiliated you
got absolutely dehumidified yes and
because of that
because of that you email him and here's
the emails asking them to take it down
i you my gosh you are damn sensitive
aren't you yeah and not only that if you
think about it if we go to your hometown
oxford education secretary slams
observed cancelling of the queens as
students at oxford magdalen college vow
vote to take down unwelcoming portrait
of the monarch from graduates common
room because she represents recent
colonial history there was an opera
about that from your city mate so i
don't know what the hell are you talking
about here we go for example making fun
mockery of the um prince philip in
animated satire the british public lost
his mind teachers losing their job you
can't even deny the holocaust even if
the architect would academically come to
make a case against denying the
holocaust you'll be imprisoned in
certain countries why is the jewish
people so sensitive aren't they cosmic
let's carry on mexico to play two world
cup
without fans due to use of islamic uh
homophobic chants
why is the homo why is the lgbqt so
sensitive aren't they
look it goes on you get the point you
get the point before i go i do want to
stress that i really don't like when
people go out of their way to insult or
offend people just for the sake of it
it's uncivilized it's unhelpful and it's
morally condemnable
but i don't criticize islam just for the
sake of it i criticized islam because it
threw the first punch by demanding my
obedience and threatening me with
hellfire for non-compliance like i said
before i don't know if you started
islamic studies which you talked about
you was going to but you definitely are
getting the damn f if i was your teacher
yeah i have to be a teacher in this very
instance because you have no damn
knowledge about islam i would give you a
flipping f
yeah yeah f for flop not even fail it's
flop yeah what the hell are you talking
about who's asking you to submit to
anything islam has its way and we have
verses in the quran to your religion to
us ours yes
we have different verses in the in the
quran yes
we have verses where to you you're
origin to us who the hell says you have
to submit where the hell are you getting
this nonsense it's absolutely pathetic
yeah please go i can find you somewhere
to study islam probably please get
contact me i'll give you a discount too
right muslims love the prophet more than
they love their mothers that's fine but
you can love whoever you please i really
don't care and i certainly won't mock
you or insult you for simply choosing to
love someone the problem is that you
don't just claim this right for yourself
right the islamic faith demands not only
your undying love for allah but mine too
it says that if i refuse to share your
love for the prophet i'm deserving of
eternal torment in the fires of hell
firstly i've never come out of such
rubbish in my life nowhere in islam does
it tell you that you have to love the
prophet or allah or islam where did you
get this from the prophet peace be upon
him to sign the treaty and hudaibiyah
yeah with the muslim yes that one of
them said that we don't recognize you as
the prophet of god they didn't say no
you have to
no you have to no the prophet peace be
upon him said delete it yeah like raise
that part where it says messenger of god
so where the hell do you get this notion
that you have to be you know if you
don't you're doomed and you're finished
where the hell do you get that from
that's why i'm telling you you need to
get some b12 and iron in your system
because oxygen is not going to your
brain i'll be honest with you call it ad
hominem or whatever you like it's so
prophetic i won't ever mock or criticize
another man's mother or brother or
sister or friend or prophet without
warrant i won't criticize anybody
without a proper justification and if i
did i'd expect quite an angry response
but if you started to claim that i must
love your mother too and that if i don't
i'll burn in hell and then if i change
my mind you'll kill me then i think a
little bit of criticism and mockery on
my part might be justifiable i mean this
is absolutely nonsense man it's a
posture this is crazy who said that you
have to love our prophet where the hell
did you get this from look let me let me
commit something clear if you're working
with your mom and i walk past you
there's going to be no part there's
going to be no problem between us
if i walk past your mom and say hi madam
and she says hi sir there'll be no
problem between us too if your mum is a
public figure and she does things which
i have deemed to be wrong i don't know
which on what
moral base as an atheist you're coming
with uh to deem anything to be right
wrong by the way yeah okay and you are
very hardcore determinist yeah i don't
know how you can even blame muslims to
be sensitive because you believe it was
determined you know your hardcore
determinist you know so what they did is
outs out of their hand so i don't know
why you can even do the video anyways
let's go with it yeah so if i want to
criticize him when i go madam there was
something that you did and i believe it
was wrong and i'm challenging you that's
criticism that's dawah we get that the
reason we do tawa is people come we
don't give dawah hi sir what know about
islam yes i want to take my shahadah
whoa except this time it doesn't work
like that people come and criticize and
ask questions for god's sake
that is different however if i'm walking
past your mom and i say you bloody
and you are
and you are this and this and this and
that and then i draw pictures of your
mom whatever it may be
you have a right to be ins um provoked
yeah you have a right to feel offended
and if you start saying if you start
going in a man and i say look at this
guy look how sensitive he is man look at
this little boy you're a little boy you
want your sense of boy yeah if i said
that you're going to be thinking to
yourself what the hell that's exactly
the same thing criticizing and insulting
the two separate things don't conflate
the two
yeah and nobody said you have to love
the prophet this is nonsense nobody's
ever said it don't insult that is our
point we're open to criticism because
islam is not exclusive yeah okay to this
vin you make it seem like it's only
muslims
muslims are the only ones my gosh go to
a bloody england match don't say a word
and walk past with an italian flag let's
see how long you lost me yeah
so don't come to me chatting breeze
about this please yeah okay
and not only that let's just touch up on
something okay the bloody ex the fake
ex-muslim community they mocked the
indian gods the hindu gods the hindu
gods yeah what happened to them they
were getting deaf reds their parents
they were getting using their pictures
of their deceased mothers
and and passing those pictures on
pornographic images they were getting
different yeah
you see how the tides turned not
mohammed himself who burst into the
kaaba after his military conquest of
mecca and destroyed every idol of pagan
worship at the site
why should you expect me to adhere to or
even respect your blasphemy laws
prohibiting me from so much as drawing
the prophet when that same prophet
himself was so blase in the destruction
of non-islamic religious symbols well
this is absolutely nonsense as well
because at the end of the day that the
kaaba was free from idol worship this is
that was original form the prophet came
to put it back to his original form
number one number two the prophet we are
told that is forbidden in the quran to
go and insult the other gods of other
people's religions it is haram yeah even
in the christians who live on the
islamic rule you're not allowed to go to
this
place of worship and damage their places
of worship you are not allowed to do
that so that is different to a a um a
conquest and after that conquest people
come in a demon for example this is a
blasphemous and getting rid of those
stuff like for example when the
rulership islamic worship took over
egypt they didn't get rid of these
statues and stuff like that yeah even
though some of them see them as deities
they didn't come and destroy them so how
is that the same we are not allowed to
insult other people's gods but this
doesn't mean that when a conquest
happens and the rulership is taken over
that the state decides what they can do
how the hell is that the same let's
carry on and i'll end on this note guys
did you know that the u.s spent half a
billion pounds on fake propaganda videos
did you know that did you know 357
um when this islamic related terrorism
whatever it may be is more on the media
357 more than any other news that are
pertaining to the same incident
that is the reason why maybe it is so
highlighted that you think islam is
sensitive let me tell you something
islam is not sensitive at all islam is
be sure when you debated muhammad hijab
and abdullah and lucy you knew what time
it is you knew and you know how strong
islam is with this literature with our
traditions and with the truth that
hundreds and thousands of people are
coming to islam in the western world
especially women we don't need so don't
make it seem like that's a weak religion
and we're sensitive you go and apply any
of these things systematically
to any other community and see what will
happen then come and tell me islam is
sensitive till then cosmic stop sending
emails to mahm and others to take videos
down because you're so damn sensitive
till next time
goodbye
you believe that this injunction to kill
apostates comes directly from god
himself and are proud of it as a result